[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi à 3 avril bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de cette édition le
début d'une mobilisation qui s'annonce
dure à la sncf les syndicats appellent à
une grève perlée de trois mois ils
protestent contre le projet de réforme
ferroviaire voulu par le gouvernement
dans ce journal le point sur le trafic
de demain mercredi à nous serons
également par téléphone avec le
secrétaire général de la cgt cheminots
de trappes axel personnes est la visite
de la ministre du travail vendredi dans
les yvelines et muriel pénicaud s'est
rendu à méré depuis plus de deux ans un
espace de coworking a ouvert dans sept
communes de moins de 2000 habitants
un nouveau mode de travail dans les
lieux partagé en pleine expansion
reportage et puis elle a fait le plein
ce week-end la coupe du monde de bmx
faisait étape à saint quentin en
yvelines pour ces à deux premières
manches est la crème mondiale de la
discipline étaient présentes devant plus
de dix mille spectateurs retour sur cet
événement
et puis nous parlerons également d'un
événement qui se déroule ce samedi aux
fermes de gally à saint cyr l'école ce
sont les universités du goût avec notre
invité amandine guglielmini un mardi
noir dont les transports avec le début
de cette grève perlée de trois mois à
lacets sncf une intersyndicale appelle à
la mobilisation jusqu'au 28 juin deux
jours de grève par semaine pour faire
reculer le gouvernement sur son projet
de réforme du rail
ouverture à la concurrence le changement
de statut de la sncf en société anonyme
ou encore la fin du statut de cheminot
al embauche pour en parler avec nous par
téléphone
axel personnes non soir alors vous êtes
le secrétaire général de la cgt
cheminots de trappes
c'est un mouvement dur qui s'annonce une
grève qui bloque le pays
des millions d'utilisateurs dans les
transports une action radicale mais
nécessaire pour faire reculer le
gouvernement
la réponse hauteur de la tâche qui leur
est lancé de la tête du niveau de
mobilisation qui autorise reportage ci
ont précédé la grève il ya plusieurs
niches et on part mais ils sont
majoritaires dans ce secteur est
aujourd'hui l'assemblée générale sera
pas rayée puis d'une centaine de
grévistes est terminée à fort qualifié
pour tenir dans la durée
fabre était important de la
consolidation les usagers qui vont pas
faire aussi de la réforme il ya pas que
les cheminots qui vont en pâtir et aussi
une volonté forte d'étendre la bataille
à d'autres secteurs qui rentre aussi en
ce moment en grève
évidemment et la bataille de l'opinion
ce que d'autres en passe de gagner comme
la tête de l'ensemble des médias
aujourd'hui et le soutient la grève en
vantant majoritaire et le soutien à la
grèce progressent fortement
tous les sondages en un athlète et de
nous et nous sentons également cette
tendance dans toutes les discussions
on va voir dans nos familles auprès de
leurs proches aux traits des visages et
les que nous entrons dans les gares et
on comprend qu'on est dans la bonne voie
et la victoire à la porte et noir en
tout cas excellent personne c'est ma
deuxième question est la dernière
question le gouvernement a dit qu'il
tiendra bon il ouvre cependant la porte
à quelques négociations notamment sur la
date des nouveaux aux employés qui
entreront sous le statut de cheminot est
ce que ça pourrait calmer votre colère
pas du tout il est tout d'abord qui le
gouvernement retire son projet de pacte
le ferroviaire et qui aussi qu'on peut
pas entamer des négociations mais sur la
base de nos revendications et pas du
tout aujourd'hui le gouvernement qu il
veut aujourd'hui en effet les modalités
de la mise en place de la taxe ne seront
pas discuter des modalités de la date à
laquelle nous allons nous faire bouffer
ce que nous voulons défendre toutes nos
revendications
dans l'ensemble de la population et une
égalité de droits entre tous les
cheminots entre les émeutes actuelles
comme fer à venir on se bat donc à la
une à venir mais aussi pour la politique
et d'acter important de l'application
phare du sublime rangers merci axel
personnes devant était avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes le secrétaire
général de
cgt cheminots de trappes on en parle est
l'une des raisons de la grève des
syndicats c'est le changement de statut
à la sncf allait advenir avec la future
loi une société anonyme à capitaux
publics les syndicats craignent que cela
n'ouvre la voie à une privatisation de
la sncf à une destruction de ce service
public ferroviaire peurs infondées pour
la députée des yvelines
aurore bergé la sncf doit cependant être
réformé écoutez là elle était l'invité
hier de nos confrères de france info
aucune ambition de détruire le service
public ferroviaire bien au contraire on
a aujourd'hui une entreprise publique à
laquelle on est toutes et tous très
attachés et les français aussi les 4
millions d'utilisateurs quotidiens de la
sncf aussi mais on sait qu'on a un
service qui s'est dégradée on sait qu'on
a un service qui doit pouvoir se
moderniser et qui ne peut pas continuer
à générer 3 milliards d'euros de dette
supplémentaire par an donc nous on a une
détermination qui elle permettre
justement la transformation de la sncf
pour que ça reste une entreprise
publique puissante et la grève qui va se
poursuivre demain mercredi une nouvelle
journée de grosse perturbation est à
prévoir sur la ligne c'est prévoir 1
train sur 5 mais attention
l'acce saint quentin en yvelines n'est
pas desservi pour la ligne rennes c'est
un train sur quatre
enfin aucune rame encore ne circulera
demain sur la ligne e u
et pour anticiper vos déplacements
n'hésitez pas à consulter les horaires
des trains sur le site transilien.com
pour éviter d'être coincé dans les
transports en commun certains d'entre
eux vont peut-être privilégiée
aujourd'hui le télétravail en
fréquentant un espace de wok de
coworking pardon c'est un nouveau mode
de travail qui se développe de plus en
plus exemple aux cinquante corps king à
méré qui recevait vendredi dernier est
l'avis de la ministre du travail mme
muriel pénicaud reportage de michael et
demi d'euros et aurélie rose ils
viennent ici tous les jours pour
certains pour d'autres
quelques heures par semaine à méré
depuis maintenant deux ans et 2050
coworking accueille une cinquantaine de
travailleurs d'un nouveau genre
un nouveau mode de travail que souhaite
déployer le gouvernement pour preuve la
visite la semaine dernière de la
ministre du travail développer les
espaces de coworking
en france c'est une bonne manière de
permettre ce que ce à quoi aspire 61 %
de nos concitoyens
c'est à dire de faire du télétravail et
en même temps d'avoir cette valeur
ajoutée de l'écosystème et du territoire
de 130 m² 25 postes de travail ou encore
une salle de réunion pour les
utilisateurs du 50 corps king ce nouveau
mode de travail présente plusieurs
avantages qu au niveau de qualité de vie
en est quand même beaucoup mieux en
télétravail puisqu'on travaille proche
de chez nous et donc au niveau du stress
et tout ça ça réduit vraiment ces
difficultés là et puis on est on est
bien mieux quand on rentre le soir à la
maison
en fait moi je suis indépendant je
pourrais être encore une fois tout seul
j'ai bien sûr les relations avec mes
clients et ça ne suffit pas en fait donc
je viens chercher ici une vraie un vrai
un vrai lien communautaire puisque un
simple bureau un esprit collaboratif des
valeurs essentielles pour cet espace de
coworking situées en zone rurale
le but c'est de garder une taille
humaine aussi qui permet de maintenir ce
lien et cette convivialité
j'ai pas d'ambition
d'agrandissement ou de multiplication
des sites
par contre j'ai une ambition
d'accompagnement sur la création
d'autres espaces de coworking et
d'autres tient lieu que ce soit sur mon
territoire ou sur le reste du territoire
national durant les prochaines semaines
la ministre du travail mme muriel
pénicaud va multiplier les déplacements
en ile de france sur la question du
télétravail et des espaces de coworking
à maurepas le projet de centre nautique
intercommunal ne fait pas l'unanimité
les élus d'opposition de gauche
s'inquiètent du coût du projet il prône
plutôt une réhabilitation de la piscine
fermée depuis 2015 pour raisons de
sécurité est les détails avec camille
lambert et nicolas danse depuis 2015 les
habitants de maurepas trouvent porte
close au centre nautique
une décision prise par le conseil
municipal et le maire de la ville
grégory gary astier pour des raisons de
sécurité l'équipe a fait le choix de
détruire la piscine pour construire un
nouvel établissement intercommunal avec
elancourt et coignières géré par un
concessionnaire privé mais l'opposition
de gauche n'approuve pas ce projet dans
notre vision des choses la publiciste
une officine de maurepas est un service
public est un service public doit être
géré par un organisme public
au lieu de dépenser des millions d'euros
à déconstruire et reconstruire
soyons intelligents réhabilitons la
piscine et faisant gagner de l'argent
omar patients de manière intelligente
dans une conjoncture budgétaire qui est
très difficile selon la mairie la
construction devrait coûter aux
alentours de 13 millions d'euros
les conseillers de l'opposition estime
le double ils ont donc décidé de déposer
un recours contre cette délibération au
tribunal administratif de versailles
les arguments qui ont été présentés aux
trois conseils municipaux pour
s'orienter vers une concession sont
fallacieux on va dire incomplet même
fallacieux puisqu'il ya un certain
nombre d'arguments côté a avancé qui
induisent les conseils municipaux en
erreur
demande au juge administratif d'alors
qu'on n'ait pas entendu sur place
on demande au juge administratif une
vérification de la légalité de
conformité à la réglementation à la loi
des délibérations prises résultats
attendus dans les prochains mois le
bâtiment actuel qui doit être détruit en
2019 est encore en sursis
politique toujours il est le nouveau
premier secrétaire fédéral du parti
socialiste des yvelines jacques chesnais
67 ans a été élu vendredi par les
militants du département
le conseiller d'opposition de marnier le
roi remporté le scrutin face au maire de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines jean claude
husson et aux morts patients ismaila
vannes
jacques chesnais qui aura la lourde
tâche de faire exister dans les yvelines
un parti en crise il dévoilera cette
semaine est la constitution de son
équipe fédérale l est républicain des
yvelines le éliront leur chef de file en
octobre prochain la droite yvelinoise
qui est sur le point de se déchirer 130
élus aient l'air ont signé une tribune
contre la candidature je cite
autoproclamé de pierre bédier le
président du département avait annoncé
briguer la tête de la fédération début
mars
parmi les signataires de la tribune
d'opposition le conseiller régional
othman nasri ou encore le maire de
vélizy pascal thévenot qui appelle au
pluralisme respectueux de chacun
cette action intervient quelques jours
seulement après un autre appel d'élus a
cette fois ci au rassemblement autour de
pierre bédier soutien notamment du maire
de poissy à karl olive ou encore de
l'édile de plaisir joséphine coleman ce
berger pierre bédier qui présidait
vendredi d'une séance du conseil
départemental à versailles plusieurs
points à l'ordre du jour les élus ont
notamment adopté un plan est
départementale pour aider les communes à
construire du logement social
et d'ici 2025 elles devront avoir à 25 %
de logements sociaux sur le territoire
en cas de non respect de la loi les
sanctions sont sévères des amendes le
des amendes lourdes et même une reprise
en main par l'état de l'urbanisme
communal et 19 villes yvelinois sont
aujourd'hui car en c est le département
se propose de les accompagner de deux
manières des propos reccueillis par
maxime le maine pour le conseil
départemental des yvelines
bien entendu une aide financière parce
que ça va coûter beaucoup d'argent mais
aussi toute une aile générique donc nous
avons ce que j'appelle le carré magique
la possibilité d'avoir des aides à
l'acquisition foncière
c'est aussi un bailleur social en
particulier qui est filiale du
département les résidences yvelines
essonne nous sommes en partenariat avec
d'autres départements à niévroz ain
c'est une société d'aménagement public
une société d'économie mixte qui
s'appelle site alios et enfin donc des
dispositifs comme celui que nous avons
voté ce matin pour rapporter des fonds
parce que ces opérations sont hors
d'atteinte budgétaire des communes et
peuvent être portés pour tout ou partie
par le département
la 8e édition de la semaine de
l'industrie s'est achevée dimanche
plusieurs événements étaient organisés
dans les yvelines pour promouvoir
l'image de l'industrie et sensibiliser
les plus jeunes c'est dans ce cadre que
justement le centre le technocentre
renault de guyancourt organiser des
visites pour lycéens et étudiants
nicolas landry nicolas quere le vide
c'est mikel et demi d'euros ont pu
suivre l'une d'elles continuer malgré
les apparences ces étudiants versailles
et ne sont pas venues faire du tourisme
en première année de classe préparatoire
scientifique ils ont la chance unique de
découvrir les locaux du technocentre de
renault
une visite dans le cadre de la semaine
de l'industrie est une opportunité pour
eux de faire leurs premiers pas dans le
monde
encore inconnu de l'entreprise c'est
beaucoup plus ludique et pédagogique
pour nous que de balayer df des fiches
avec des métiers et des choses qui nous
parle c'est beaucoup plus concret nous
dit beaucoup quand on va arriver en
entreprise tout ce qu'on a appris va
changer et qu'on va apprendre beaucoup
sur le tas et si ça permet d'anticiper
un peu cette période là qui peut faire
faire peur parce que l'on arrive en
entreprise jeune on peut penser qu'on
qu'on connaît tous et en fait pas du
tout dans les couloirs du technocentre
la trentaine d'étudiants observent
écoutent et interroge aussi pour la
première fois depuis 2001 l'industrie
française est redevenue créatrice
d'emplois l'an passé et le secteur
automobile est l'un des plus performants
du secteur
ces jeunes qu'on reçoit aujourd'hui
c'est potentiellement les ingénieurs de
demain donc potentiellement ma relève
donc c'est toujours intéressant de leur
présenter nos métiers il ya beaucoup
d'opportunités dans l'automobile en ce
moment et donc je pense que il faut
communiquer là dessus et leur dire
qu'ils sont les bienvenus pour tenter
d'attirer les jeunes talents le
technocentre a accueilli 250 élèves
durant cette 8e édition de la semaine de
l'industrie
en ile de france près de 700 événements
étaient organisés au total et lors de
cette visite michael et demi d'euros et
nicolas landry ont pu s'entretenir avec
la responsable de l'opération octet au
technocentre
interview la 8e édition de la semaine de
l'industrie au technocentre renault de
guyancourt une semaine qui est piloté
par karine robert chapuis
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
responsable des relations externes et
des visites au technocentre en quoi
consiste la semaine de l'industrie
ici au technocentre renault de
guyancourt en fait nous avons organisé
une dizaine de visites
donc toute la semaine toute la matinée
et l'après midi donc ce soir nous serons
accueillis environ 250 élèves et
étudiants notamment des lycéens et des
étudiants post bac
qu'est ce que vous leur faites découvrir
à traverser ces visites
en fait l'objectif c'est de découvrir
l'industrie automobile et les métiers du
technocentre
c'est un secteur d'industrie qui est
assez mal va très peu connue des jeunes
notamment des lycéens et des étudiants
post bac et l'objectif ici c'est
vraiment de le faire immergé dans ce
métier du technocentre
comment vous expliquez cette
méconnaissance du secteur automobile du
secteur industriel en général
voilà je sais pas peut-être parce qu'on
pense que si on travaille dans
l'automobile ont fait que deux moteurs
et des boîtes peut-être donc c'est une
méconnaissance assez générales et c mais
ici on a une multitude une diversité de
métiers différents qui part de
l'enseigné
et de l'après vente mais aussi à la
logistique et de maquettage numérique
par exemple alors vous l'avez dit vous
accueillez des lycéens mais pas que il
semblerait pas que effectivement nous
accueillons également des étudiants qui
sont en post-bac donc du dut souvent de
sciences d'ingénieurs mais aussi des
écoles préparatoires scientifiques alors
c'est un public un peu plus concerné
puisque il s'oriente vraiment dans le
secteur justement industriels des
secteurs de l'ingénierie qu'est ce que
vous leur apportez ces types de puits à
ce type de public en fait ces locations
pour les chaînes ses étudiants peut-être
pour la première fois dans toute entrée
dans une grande entreprise et d'avoir un
intervenant un jeune ingénieur à pouvoir
échanger pour pouvoir savoir c'est qu'en
quoi consiste le métier d'ingénieur
conceptuel aujourd'hui au sein du
technocentre et pouvoir faire des
échanges tout simplement on cherche
également toute l'année des stagiaires
et d'apprentis sur le site technocentre
justement j'allais en venir ça permet
aussi de tisser des liens justement de
trouver des stagiaires des apprentis
combien vous en accueillez à peu près
fait sur le technocentre
j'ai peur de vous redonner
bêtise chivot donald chiffres mais nous
accueillons toute l'année dans plein de
directions différentes
testa cher et des apprentis qui viennent
plutôt de quelle école de take two tels
quels types de formations souvent des
écoles d'ingénieurs évidemment le
technocentre est le premier centre de
recherche et de développement en europe
donc ici au technocentre on a une très
grande population d'ingénieurs le but
aussi je suppose que c'est pour les
lycéens de créer peut-être des vocations
oui aussi il existe des carrefours
métiers organisé par des lésés mais il y
a aussi des visites qui sont organisées
par plusieurs sociétés dont le
technocentre le groupe 9 pour faire
découvrir des métiers qu'on connaissait
pas forcément avant surtout qu'en
septembre 2018 il ya le campus
automobile de guyancourt qui va ouvrir
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ce type
de structure il peut aussi avoir des
liens et puis aussi avoir des visites
bien évidemment avec le campus qui est
situé effectivement juste à proximité de
nous faut et donc voilà donc 250
étudiants lycéens qui ont pu découvrir
le technocentre de guyancourt durant
cette 8e édition de la semaine de
l'industrie sport les deux premières
manches de la coupe du monde de bmx se
sont tenues ce week end à saint quentin
en yvelines l'événement a été suivi par
plus de dix mille spectateurs une
ambiance des grands jours qui a sublimé
les pilotes français retour sur
l'événement avec michael medoro et
nicolas landry des tribunes pleines à
craquer un grand show à l'américaine et
les meilleurs pilotes mondiaux de bmx
sur la piste
un cocktail qui a permis à la première
manche de la coupe du monde d'afficher
complet ce samedi 31 mars et ce dimanche
1er avril au vélotour national avec plus
de 10000 à spectateurs
c'est assez sympa c'est les gens peuvent
être assez proche de la piste et du coup
c'est assez participatif
on peut approcher les compétiteurs alors
on peut voir les grands pilotes français
s'affronter avec les meilleurs européens
et et pilotes internationaux donc ça
fait plaisir de les voir au niveau quoi
un succès populaire inédit pour la
france- qui n'avait plus accueilli deux
manches de coupe du monde depuis sept
ans un vrai plus pour les pilotes
tricolores selon leur staff
ça nous fait toujours un immense plaisir
de courir à domicile
c'est à une saveur un peu particulière
donc donc oui je dirais que oui on a un
petit comme on dit en anglais comme
advantage le pilote qui est le plus
profité de cet avantage à domicile c'est
lui joris daudet le pilote du stade
bordelais 2 fois vainqueur de la
couronne mondiale en 2011 et 2016 a
terminé troisième de la première manche
le samedi et 1er 24 heures plus tard
suis vraiment content de gagner ici à la
maison à paris
c'est vraiment exceptionnel le public
est exceptionnel tout le week end encore
merci à j'espère qu'on aura une autre
coupe du monde ici en france ' l'année
prochaine avant de penser à l'année
prochaine et un possible retour de la
compétition à saint quentin en yvelines
les pilotes mondiaux s'affronteront les
5 et 6 mai aux pays bas pour la deuxième
manche de la coupe du monde en football
on jouait ce week-end les demi-finales
de la coupe des yvelines maurepas s'est
imposé sur le terrain de plaisir une
place en finale acquise après une séance
de tirs au but le résumé de la rencontre
nickel et demi d'euros et nicolas
dandrieaux buts marqués une victoire au
bout du suspense de maurepas face à
plaisir pourtant tout avait mal commencé
pour les verts dans cette demi finale de
coupe des yvelines avec cette ouverture
du score des plaisirs oit sur leur
terrain juste avant la mi temps où on a
joué à la baballe on joue à deux à
l'heure sans intensité
au final on se fait contrer c'était sûr
que ça allait se passer comme ça et on
prend notre but comme ça donc on a fait
le taf
une occasion un but il faudra faire une
meilleure deuxième mi temps je pense au
retour des vestiaires les contre
attaques s'enchaînent pour plaisir après
un premier avertissement et que ce tir
sur le poteau
les attaquants arrivent à combiner pour
faire le break 2 à 0
mal en point les murs parisiens
réagissent dans la foulée sur coup franc
avant d'égaliser dans les dernières
secondes pour arracher la séance de tirs
au but
[Musique]
c'est super dur sata un coup au moral on
se dit 2 0 il reste même pas deux trois
minutes sont cependant d'un de deux par
l'ensam un coup au moral mais voilà
prenant mais on essaye d'être commandes
du professionnel et garder la tête haute
finalement plaisir à deux penalties
s'incline 4 tirs au but à 3 maurepas
jouera la finale de la coupe des
yvelines pour la deuxième fois en trois
un scénario du match fixé il ya encore
plus de bonheur égalisent à la dernière
seconde après les tirs au but sur la
loterie un peu mais ça fait trois fois
qu'on passe aux tirs au but donc on peut
dire qu'on conduit assez à l'aise dans
l'exercice finalement dans l'autre
demi-finale du haut cours s'est imposé
5-1 face à hardricourt les deux équipes
de d1 de district se rencontreront le 3
juin prochain à maisons-laffitte avec
moi sur ce plateau amandine guglielmini
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
chargé de marketing et de développement
aux fermes de gally à saint-cyr-l'ecole
les fermes de gally qui organise ce
samedi à la 4éme y est la quatrième
édition des universités du boost une
journée complète sur la thématique on va
présenter quelques pièces de quelques
éléments du programme dans un instant
déjà une première question pourquoi
organiser un tel événement qu'elle est
finalement l'objectif de ces universités
du goût les universités du goût sont une
journée de rencontres de débats et
d'ateliers autour du goût pour défendre
le goût du bon dans l'alimentation
d'accord parce que nous sommes persuadés
que en comprenant mieux la construction
et la fabrication du goût on va pouvoir
au quotidien faire des bons choix dans
notre alimentation et soutenir la
filière agricole française
on a l'impression que cette thématique
du goût du bien manger on
de plus en plus attentifs à cette
thématique comment l'expliquer à votre
avis nous l'expliquent en disant que
goûter c'est osé accueillir le monde en
soit c'est à dire qu'en fait quand on
mange on ne se contente pas de
simplement manger mais c'est un acte qui
est vraiment profond puisque on ingère
on ingère les choses et en fait c'est
assez révélateur de qui nous sommes
aussi bien individuellement que
collectivement et donc donc en mangeant
en fait on devient on devient acteur
social
alors il ya une thématique pour cette
quatrième édition c'est la mémoire et le
goût certainement on a tous une
madeleine de proust je suppose que vous
avez la vôtre et donc l'idée c'est de
comprendre mieux pourquoi
pourquoi on réagit d'une certaine
manière face à notre alimentation
pourquoi on aime ou pourquoi on aime pas
voilà il fit donc voilà toute cette
journée s'articule autour de la mémoire
alors cette journée d'ailleurs un
programme chargé de 10h à 17h30 quatre
grands sujets vont être abordés tout au
long de cette journée qui va être animée
autour de conférences des changes mais
également de récréation dégustative
exactement donc on commencera la journée
avec une conférence sur le bébé
gastronomes puisqu'en fait la
construction du goût se passe quand on
est enfant vous aimiez peut-être les
épinards et moi non quand j'étais
aujourd'hui oui comme quoi même voilà
est donc en fait comment pourquoi vous
les aimiez pas et moi non plus et
pourquoi aujourd'hui on les aime à quel
moment intervient le changement est ce
qu'il faut obliger les enfants à manger
des épinards ou est-ce que simplement et
peut-être des subterfuges pour pour
réussir à faire en sorte que son enfance
alimente correctement en fait ce sera
tout l'objet de la première conférence
d'accord et on continuera sur cette
belle lancée avec un médecin
nutritionniste qui lui nous expliquera
comment acquérir les bons réflexes pour
une alimentation saine est aussi une
alimentation plaisir dès la tendre
enfance
d'ailleurs il y aura des spécialistes
présents pour ces universités donc la
première conférence est animée par une
une docteur en neurosciences et puis la
seconde par un médecin nutritionniste
ensuite on va vous proposer de se
retrouver avec un économiste et des
producteurs pour ensemble réfléchir
comment le terroir peut faire face à la
mondialisation comment l'innovation peut
s'insérer même sûr
sur des produits de terroir très bien et
aussi quelles sont les difficultés qu'on
peut rencontrer parce qu'on a tous envie
de manger des bons produits on n'a pas
forcément tous envie de payer le prix
qu'ils valent donc ce sera vraiment
l'objet de cette table ronde ou qui sera
éclairée par le témoignage de
producteurs qui ont les mains dans le
cambouis y ait chaque jour pour faire le
le goût pour le fabriquer et cet
économiste qui apportera un regard plus
+ macroéconomique alors tout de ce
programme on le retrouve bien sûr un sur
le site internet de l'événement un
dernier mot pour s'inscrire pour
participer à cette journée comment fait
on va sur les sites internet les
universités du goût point fr et puis
tout est indiqué en ligne et je rappelle
que c'est donc à partir de 10 heures ce
samedi 7 avril aux fermes de gally
mercier amandine gory albini peut-être
un mot ajouté si vous ne pouvez pas
venir il y aurait un facebook live et
tout sera remis sur youtube
ensuite merci le préciser je rappelle
vous êtes chargé de marketing et de
développement aux fermes de gally à
saint cyr d'école ces images pour
refermer ce journal de nombreuses
chasses aux oeufs ont eu lieu ce week
end en ce week-end prolongé de pâques
comme vous le voyez ici à montigny le
bretonneux le conseil de quartier des
prés organisé la quatrième édition de sa
chasse aux oeufs au square charles péguy
dimanche plus de 300 personnes ont pris
part aux recherches 1500e était cachée
dans le parc des jeux et animations
étaient également proposés les objectifs
de la journée au micro de nicolas landry
c'est un bon moment tous ensemble pour
les enfants hamas et d euros chocolat la
première année on l'annoncé ça et ça
très très bien marché et chaque année on
l'a on l'a fait elle et elle est
demandée parce que là c'est la seule
chasse à montigny-le-bretonneux
nous sommes le seul quartier des
affaires à le faire voilà c'est la fin
de ce set 8 journal replay et reportages
à retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv à 60,18
belle soirée à tous
[Musique]